look out principal honey is in the house
[Music]
mr. honey's not wonderful but karez what
does it feel like being Riverdale's
newest addition I'll tell you something
this role is full circle for me remember
this one day on Dawson's Creek where we
got a new principal at Capeside high it
was Harry Shearer was playing the
character and he was interrogating
students and because I think we put
maybe his boat in a pool or something
like that I forget what it was cut to 18
years later Here I am Riverdale high is
nude principal and I'm interrogating
students for we know whatever they've
done it's just it's very very strange
for me you may be honey but I will
always be the queen bee you have no
power over me christmas is coming on who
a lot of fans know and love from
Dawson's Creek were you a big Dawson's
Creek fan I know
unfortunately no no no it's not that I
wasn't it's just I never watched it yeah
I wasn't no I was too young I was too
young for that I was like Gossip Girl
era you know so can't say that I was but
I was a final destination yeah yeah so I
obviously know of him and we were really
excited to have him on board he's a
super sweet guy and really good really
good at the role I love how everything
comes full circle yeah and I was really
really impressed working with him he's
an insanely talented person I don't like
drama miss Lodge I'm curious to know did
you happen to catch any episodes of
Riverdale before you joined the show yes
yes absolutely and what did you think
you're entering into a very intense
world yeah it's it's pretty dramatic a
little strange everything's you know
kind of do the sets are so dark and
smoky it's like what are we shooting
here a thriller but I'm used to it so
it's fun what has it been like being the
Nuvi on set you know KJ and Charles are
quite the pranksters has they done any
newbie hazing yet no they have not hazed
me whatsoever thank you for warning me
though I will be on the lookout I feel
like you could just put them directly
into detention though I think they're
probably a little afraid of me I mean
mr. honey not so sweet
is any
ever suite in Riverdale so what can you
tell us about it he's a no-nonsense kind
of guy this high school was is his
castle and he runs it the way that he
wants I don't know what kind of a ship
Waldo Weatherby was running around here
things are gonna be different this year
we'll have order discipline consequences
now get out of my sight it's very
strange for me I'm used to playing
Archie or Jughead I'm used to be in the
high school kid and now the sudden I'm
the principal so it's very very strange
what's it like being on the adult side
of things now I prefer the kids side
really
yeah I'm still 14 in here so you know
what can you tease about what principal
honey is up to and the Halloween
opposite well let's just say I do some
interrogation myself as to a few things
that happen in the high school I take a
few of them aside and say hey this is my
house right play by my rules we have a
new enemy in our midst this killjoy is
our new principal mr. honey never fear I
as your student body president will make
sure that he's the headed by homecoming
but the Halloween episode is cool you
know we've got things everywhere like
the high schools all decorated it'll be
like a mummy on one of the benches by
the lockers and you think it's a student
sleeping but it's not it's a mummy or a
witch so it's kind of cool and from what
you've told me about principal honey
something tells me he's not really into
costumes no other than a three-piece
suit you'd know about that wouldn't you
we're in the day and age of reunions and
reboots mm-hmm they are rebooting
everything how would you feel if they
either wanted to do a Dawson's Creek
reunion or a complete reboot I'd be into
it I mean I'm actually involved in in a
possible situation so we'll see yeah I
can't talk about it but oh yeah did we
just don't want something you might have
you might have but that's all I'm giving
you one so okay so it'd be a reunion
we're working on it we'll see okay who
have you been chatting with I can't tell
you that
but who from the cast do you still talk
with no can't tell you that how's James
James is fine
[Music]